it everything else technology keeps on
rolling on sometimes there are benefits
to new technology and sometimes there
are things that aren't don't work out so
well so for instance what we try to do
is we always try to take the best of
Mother Nature and combine it with the
best of technology we find that that
Union works really really well we try to
stay away from anything experimental or
unproven and go back to basics
technology also is unfortunately faddish
in the same way that sometimes we see
this with food no fat low fat high carb
high protein you know it's what are you
supposed to eat and people tend to jump
on a bandwagon that is generated by the
press so one day and ingredient whether
it could be a very efficacious good
ingredient but if it's fallen out of
favor out it goes and then the
technology has to change to compensate
for that so but on the other end you
know technology does bring advances you
know those advances and anti-aging and
sun protection so the things that are
very legitimate but the knife cuts both
ways yeah I can't think of any real
specific technologies like dramatically
different technologies that have come in
to apply maybe sunscreen since we
started our business yeah we're the
biggest the biggest one would be
oil-free moisturizer which would
probably been in the last 20 years well
I think it would be more fats like
you're saying you know organic had
become a real big thing over the past
few years and it's sort of died down a
lot lately you know and that was never a
bandwagon we jumped on and as Andrew was
saying you know we utilize gentle
technologies that are tried true and
trusted along with those natural
ingredients similarly try to entrusted
in the most gentle efficacious manner so
that you're never finding irritation and
hopefully getting the very best
performance so we're not necessarily
looking for what the newest technology
is if we can incorporate something that
is trustful into the brand we don't need
to reinvent the wheel every sing
season and then again we're not against
organic ingredients and the problem is
is that they've been so misrepresented
to the customer saying this is organic
but you look then you read the
ingredients and it's one ingredient
which is point zero two percent of the
product and then the customer finally
figures this out and is disappointed and
then they have to ship this organic
ingredient halfway from around the world
so the carbon footprint that it produces
is so bad for the planet so and there
was a really organic eyes are grown
indoors you know was there acid rain
right so organic isn't necessarily
better always I mean what we try to do
is always horrible I many locally
continues natural when we can and
organic if it's available but we don't
use that as the litmus test because
there are many more important things
that go into the full formula